hi jordan how are you i'm doing really
good how are you
i am well i appreciate you uh talking to
me about the show especially now it
feels like somebody won't hurt me for
you know because i don't it won't be a
spoilery anymore exactly it won't be on
you twitter has it for sure yeah it was
a little hard to talk about when it
started so this is better
yes
well i'm curious i mean now that the
series has been available for a little
bit what has most surprised you about
the reaction to the show what are people
most responding to is there anything
you're surprised they're responding to
um
i've noticed that people have been
responding to the soundtrack a lot which
i completely agree with it's absolutely
brilliant um
and
it is such an important part because it
like sets the the mood and tone you know
to have music playing so um not that i
was surprised but um i've been noticing
a lot of that
have you been seeing reactions to your
character at all i mean i personally
love the sister relationship on the show
so what what are you seeing like as far
as the story lines go
yeah i love seeing um people being
supportive and rooting for the sister um
relationship i am also rooting for that
for sure
um but yeah i mean it's kind of weird
because i
i don't know what i'm seeing like i
don't know if it's being tailored to me
because i'm only seeing good stuff like
maybe twitter is protecting me or
something but i'm really only seeing
good stuff
when the opportunity to be a part of
this
became a possibility for you what was
your reaction had you been familiar with
the original series are you somebody who
is typically interested in reboots and
remakes and reimaginings i mean what was
your reaction to
well i typically really like team dramas
like
things like that like i was really into
pretty little liars and i watched gossip
girl as well
um
so i was i was excited and i was down
and um you know as an auditioning actor
mostly you're just very down
you know like whatever it is give it to
me but this was this was unique and
special in that um i already knew that
emily allen lind was going to be a part
of it and we'd worked together
previously on um sacred lies so it had
that added element of just you know
knowing someone on the cast and just
thinking that it'd be a really fun
opportunity
what was the audition process like for
this did you when you auditioned for
this did you immediately have a good
feeling about it are you someone who's
always convinced you'll never get
whatever it is
um i
as long as i'm in the audition
mode i am i am getting this role and
then when you audition you just forget
about it you just have to you know
because there's
you just gotta
send your energy elsewhere but
definitely like focusing
all of my energy onto the positive
outcome
um while it's like available
but
it was a it was an interesting
auditioning process i heard about um the
reboot from emily and so she was like
you need to audition so kind of started
that way and
it was about february and then i heard
nothing so i was like oh well and then
also
the pandemic happened
um
and then in august i was going for a
screen test which was actually just like
a zoom call with cassandra the casting
director which was crazy
i remember sweating because i closed all
the doors in my room to like make sure
that it's like looks good and quiet i'm
just like
[Music]
at what point did you meet whitney and
and how did you guys start to figure out
the dynamic between your characters
yeah so whitney is just such an
incredible
wonderful human being um
[Music]
i think i was maybe like the second last
to get cast so there was a lot you know
she'd been she'd known that she was
gonna be in it from maybe like march or
something um so then when i got cash she
reached out to me immediately like gave
me her number and we had like a phone
call which was really nice and
it really felt immediate just like the
bond with her she's actually from the
place where i was born so there was all
of this kind of interesting
um stuff happening even before we got
into the script
i read that you decided to shave your
head when you were 18 which is a bold
move at any time since it's one of those
things where you just don't know the
outcome until you actually do it then
it's sort of too late to go back
so i i also love that you still have
that shaved head on this show
did anyone ever
suggest you for you to try anything else
for the role or were you always clear
that this is who this character is
i mean
i don't think that
that they had intended for julian to
have a shaved head i don't know that
that was really like in the write-up
um
and
i was open to the idea you know um in
terms of doing acting like i'm i'm very
open to
you know creating what the character is
supposed to be so i was like if you guys
want me to wear a wig like i could wear
a wig but they ended up going with
leaving my hair shaved and i was so
excited about that because
you know it was i guess kind of a risk
when i did it just like
you know
i
definitely got commented on a lot when
when i first shaved my head i feel like
the comments are less now because maybe
i just have had it for so long that
nobody cares but
um you know it can kind of be
um something that you're discouraged
from doing so maybe if someone can see
me and know that they can do it if
that's what they want to do then that's
good
it also seems like one of those things
that just inherently has a certain sense
of confidence to it because it seems
like it'd be really scary to do
otherwise
yeah i mean
it's funny because maybe it's just hard
for me to remember what i was feeling
but i think that
when i decide something i it's very like
cut you know um and my hair was maybe
about like that long when i shaved it
and
i just don't remember feeling any
trepidation or any
you know like
i was like this is what i'm doing and
that's it's a hundred percent the right
decision
so
for whatever reason i don't know i don't
know why because definitely it wasn't
because people were encouraging me to do
it quite the opposite
this character is someone who is very
self-assured and confident and centered
especially when we meet her
where did you find the inspiration for
that is that
something that you find within yourself
was that something you had to find
outside of yourself
i think that i had to kind of rework the
way that my confidence works to
channel it through julian
um
but
i think it is kind of the same thing
essentially
we have different outcomes because we
believe different things i think um but
it's that idea that like you know what
you want and you're gonna do it and it's
not really about um
you know what other people are gonna say
and so she's just kind of
although she does get lost a little bit
along the way you know
luna and monet definitely have a lot to
say
but um yeah i think that that's like the
core of her character and where like a
lot of her confidence stems from is that
she's like really believes um that she
knows best
one of the things that like i said i
find most interesting about this show is
that sister relationship at the core and
how it's constantly evolving
what are you finding most interesting
about that dynamic and
and how it has evolved since you started
playing
so my favorite thing about it um which i
think is the truth about siblings and
family and friends is that when those
people are your people no matter what
happens you like you make it through
kind of thing so
obviously we're literally only what is
it four episodes in and zoya and julian
have do you have had to deal with some
insane challenges in terms of like
maintaining their relationship and their
love for each other and
every time you see that
love wins um above all of the drama
above all of the misunderstandings and i
think that that's like a really exciting
lesson you know and that's the thing
that i love the most is that they their
love for each other is so resilient
and pretty early on there's already a
guy creating tension between them so how
do you feel about that
weird kind of love triangle are you
someone who is like no this shouldn't be
happening because they're sisters do you
think it's fun to play
um i think it's really funny and
interesting
um
i feel like it is so bizarre to me
because
i just wouldn't even register
people who were with my sisters
as
anything you know like that would be so
far beyond
like the realm of possibility um so i do
think it's interesting because you know
gossip girl is this kind of heightened
imaginative fantasy world and you know
the stranger the storyline the more
drama you get so
i definitely think it is weird but you
know i'm sure it happens
yeah and they're they're also you know
technically strangers they they don't
they didn't grow up as sisters so it's
well
exactly that's the other thing they're
not they don't have what i think repels
people from their siblings partners you
know which is that deep rooted like
connection you know they don't have that
so technically it is a little bit fair
game so yeah that's a good point
it's hard to know sometimes what
jillian's true motivations are with
anything also because they do keep
shifting
she seems genuine but then it seems like
she's manipulating everything and then
she seems genuine again so do you like
keeping her unpredictable and unexpected
in that way
yeah
i do because
i think that it is kind of like um an
exaggeration of how people truly are i
don't think people necessarily oscillate
quite as much as julian does in terms of
her like moral
fixation but
i think that to a certain extent like we
do contradict ourselves as humans you
know we can say well i'm against this
and then a certain situation happens and
you're like
hang on you know so we are vast and
multitudinous and i think that
um you know
julian represents that in the ways that
like people just contradict themselves
and you may care about something and
want the best for it but
when something else happens all of a
sudden that becomes second
we haven't really gotten too many
details yet on their mother so are we
gonna learn more about
who she was and and how that is gonna
continue to affect things for them
yeah definitely the legacy of their
mother
is something that comes into play later
in the season um and i
really hope that there will be more
about it because she's a very
interesting character
you know as everyone just saw in the
uh episode 4
you know she
kind of ran out on my dad and me you
know and if that isn't gossip girl
worthy drama
i don't know what is
one of the big moments in the show
happened in the first episode with the
fashion show what was that whole
sequence like to shoot with everything
going on the runway the incredible dress
all of that stuff what was that like to
do
it was amazing and it felt real you know
i never oh i did walk in a fashion show
one time anyway um
it just it felt like i'm like i don't
know
what would be more real about this like
there was cameras there's audience
there's the catwalk um when we do it we
did full passes of it so you way back
you wait backstage everybody goes out
and then
um you know so i was like this just
feels like re like a real fashion show
and there were real models those girls
are not actors they they're they're
models who frequently work with
christopher john rogers so that was also
really cool um it was great though you
know karina evans directed it in a very
beautiful way and um at the end of it
because it was a very long day and i was
wearing like louboutins something like
this much of a heel just walking back
and forth constantly um and at the end
of it you know she
we all came out and everybody did like
an applause because we we were all there
for a very long time and it was nice to
just have that
finale moment where it's like we did
this and just everybody congratulate
themselves
what was it like to also shoot the
sequence
at the party where julian
bullies zoya with the video of her being
bullied i mean that whole
sequence is so impactful and emotional
how did it feel to shoot that scene and
to have her have that realization that
she is also being a bully herself
it was uh personally it was very
stressful for me i love whitney and like
even in the imaginary world of like
doing something mean to her just so i
remember i was sitting there like eating
my lunch and she was asking me something
i literally just like broke my fork
because i was just like
you know it was just like a lot it was a
lot and um
i had to do it so
many times i had to say those things so
many times and knowing that the intent
of the first speech was to just like
hurt her as much as possible i was just
like oh god it was awful but you know um
we do it
yeah and it seems so tricky to do that
and still have it come back around and
have her sort of redeem herself by the
end of the episode i mean that's a lot
to do
it's it's a complete yeah it's a full 80
it's a full 180 you know because it's
like
well and then that's exactly the
contradictory nature of julian like okay
all of a sudden she's a hundred percent
a thousand percent sure that she wants
to absolutely destroy her sister
and then
something else comes to light and it's
like oh actually i'm a hundred percent
thousand percent gonna you know expose
myself and save her in the course of
like
10 minutes so it's definitely uh
you know but
she's young and i think that maybe
that's how those types of things happen
when you're young like
you really get convinced in one aspect
and then you realize i might have been
wrong about that and so i feel like that
that's what that moment was where she
really
thought that she was right to do what
she was doing and then realized that it
was really [ __ ] up
can we also talk about that outfit you
wear at that party the sheer sparkly
mesh dress i mean when when you're
wearing wardrobe like that does it
affect even how you carry yourself
completely i mean i couldn't walk
properly really um and i couldn't really
sit down in it because it hurt um but
yeah i mean it really just
forces you a lot of julian's clothes and
just like
her character in general kind of makes
me like hold myself differently and have
different mannerisms which is
very fun and interesting like she's a
very
you know
curated and crafted individual
ashland was a huge part of the original
series and it seems like it's also a
pretty defining characteristic of this
series
how do you feel about her wardrobe
everything from you know how she styles
her school uniform to everyday life to
what she wears when she dresses up do
you feel like there's one way to
describe your style or is it more of a
mix of things
i feel like it's definitely a mix of
things
um
one of the things would definitely be
you know the thing that falls into the
category of the
diamond dress and like the shoulder pad
cat suits you know there's like that
vein but then um she also
does some more like low-key maybe
streetwear inspired
um oversized androgynous vibe and then
she also does have
that kind of like um
cutesy like tall boots little mini skirt
thing so i feel like there's like three
things happening and it's dependent on
her mood or something
onset does the cast of students and the
cast of teachers stay separate even
though you guys are all sort of
approximately the same age or do you all
hang out together
um we definitely hang out together if
we're all on set together the thing
about it is that um the teachers are
always obviously gonna have their scenes
together a lot so
um you know they'll be on there on days
that we aren't maybe but if if
everybody's there at once oh we're all
together for sure yeah
how does julian feel about gossip girl
does she care about finding out who
gossip girl is and what was your
reaction to finding out how that was
going to be set up for the show
yeah that was that was so interesting i
mean
i guess for me i felt like
it was the right thing to do because you
spent all of um you know
the first gossip girl trying to figure
out who gossip girl is and so i think
that it would really make sense to kind
of flip that on its head and it's like
you know from junk you know just really
kind of
you know
making a distinction between each of the
gossip girl eras um and julian
i feel like
she hasn't gotten to the point yet where
she's wondering who gossip girl is i
feel like especially in this day and age
there's so many
um you know accounts and it's like
nobody really knows who's who it is and
you just kind of accept it as like you
know
living on the internet right so i don't
know that she's
started to think about that but that is
really interesting you know starting a
plot line where it's like wait a second
who is this like i feel like everyone's
just kind of accepting that it's some
online troll but behind every online
troll is a human
usually unless it's a bot i guess
do you get excited about the connections
between the original series and this one
do they do those get pointed out to you
ahead of time or do you just have to
catch them when the script comes
yeah i mean i i catch them
um
sometimes and then a lot of the times i
i get it from online i get it from
twitter like um there was a scene in the
first episode where i take a scarf and
put it around zoya and then there's a
scene just like that with blair and
serena and a thousand percent the cat or
the writers and creators are doing that
on purpose because it very much is like
a union you know this is an extension in
the next era it's not um taking gossip
girl away from what it already was you
know so i think leaving those easter
eggs for the fans of the original show
is really fun i i love it too
yeah it's definitely fun and it's i
think it's a cool way to connect the two
for the first season because then you're
not necessarily waiting for like any of
the original cast to show back up so
that you guys can definitely
establish your characters and have your
moment
but still you know pay homage to what
came before definitely yeah
what can you say to to tease what's
still to come in the first season what
what do you think are the biggest ways
the audience will still be surprised by
the show i mean by the the story you're
continuing to tell
i mean
every
episode is just so
could be so contained in terms of like
the entertainment value of
everything that's going on you know the
different plot lines and the events and
just all of the extravagant drama so
it's it's just it's more of that you
know every episode i feel like leaves
you like
the whole time so um definitely a lot of
that and
a tease about the next episode is that
there will be a lot of costumes which is
going to be very fun
we also have seen jillian looking for
at least
some kind of romance in all the wrong
places
so will she find anything more right for
her
you know
it's definitely
kind of still up in the air
i think that
um julian
there's a lot going on in her life
that causes her to
focus a lot on herself and that doesn't
necessarily bode well for having like a
deep intimate connection with someone as
we saw with obi you know he's like oh i
don't even feel like i exist you and you
know that's kind of true where julian's
at you know she's just very focused on
herself and like
how to kind of create this online image
and
so
yeah i feel like i feel like it's going
to take her some time still to kind of
deconstruct all of that
yeah it certainly seems like it's kind
of challenging to have a genuine
connection with someone when you don't
even fully know who you are or that you
know while that's changing and evolving
yeah i feel like it's very much that
well i appreciate you talking to me
about the show and everything i just i
think it's been so much fun i didn't
know what to expect from you know the
return of the show and all of these new
characters and
and i think
sending it around this sister dynamic
makes it really interesting yay well i'm
so glad that you're enjoying it and
having fun and it was absolutely lovely
to talk to you i love your setup back
there i'm like seeing a lot of posters
and cool stuff and i like that yeah i i
love concerts and i'm a concert
photographer and it's just been like my
heart has been so like sad without
having any of that to do so
i try to at least keep the art up i love
that well hey fingers crossed for things
coming back
yeah for sure
and thank you so much for this i love if
nothing else i love watching it because
the fashion is insane i love that
thank you so much